So after having looped through,
after having iterated through the entire
dataset, millions and millions of tags.
Okay?
Then what I'm going to do is print out
the data that I found for my audit.
Okay?
So it actually takes a little while for
that to run.
So I've run it already.
Okay.
And here's what the output looks like.
Okay so there actually aren't
really that many unusual values.
What I find is, so
in the United States, and
this is going to vary from one country
to another, in the United States,
we number certain types of roads.
So this would be a US highway.
United States highway.
Same thing with 53, 59,
and so on, all right?
So that's why I'm seeing these as keys,
all right?
Now this is odd.
My guess is, these look like zip codes
to me, or postal codes, all right?
Another road number.
And then I'm seeing
different forms of avenue.
And as I move through this,
here's a good example of a set for
this particular key value here for
court.
Okay, so these are all of the different
uses of CT as an abbreviation for
court in this particular dataset.
Okay, and
as I scroll through this, I see
the rest of the unusual street types.
Okay, now what I have to decide,
and basically this
is the process that you're going to
follow through the next few exercises,
is, which of these are okay and which of
them do I need to do something about?
South Avenue L,
that's actually a correct way of
representing a street name, there's
nothing wrong with that it's just
that it wasn't expected in my audit.
It's okay though,
I would probably not want to do anything
to change how this is represented.
On the other hand, I don't really
like all caps abbreviations.
So I would probably transform
all of the abbreviations
into the specific word
that that represents.
So, for example,
PKWY is an abbreviation for
Parkway okay, so
that's what I would probably use there.
All right and the same with other
abbreviations that we find here, street,
terrace, and so on.
Okay, so your general process for
the exercises that follow is going to be
to write some code, to audit the data,
and then decide what type of fixes
you want to apply to that data.
And then write the code that
actually performs the fix.